-Our next guest is
a talented actress
you know from her work
in the TV series "Shameless,"
as well as films such as
"The Phantom of the Opera"
and "Mystic River."
She both executive produced
and stars in "Angelyne," which
is available now on Peacock.
Let's take a look.
-So, boys, what's this about?
Harold tells me
you're a fan of Angelyne.
Me too.
-Well, as I was
just telling Harold,
your billboard
at Sunset and Vine
is in a prime location
for one of our clients.
-Hmm. Who's the client?
-We'd like to take over
the lease contract.
And we're willing to throw in
a couple thousand extra
to sweeten the deal.
It's a very generous offer.
-Well, gentlemen, this is not
my decision to make.
Please talk to my partner.
-[ Chuckles ]
-Uh, no offense, but this
might be above your head.
-Hmm, I -- I just --
I don't see anything up there.
-Please welcome back to
the show, Emmy Rossum, everyone.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Up-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
-Hi, Emmy, welcome back.
-Hi. Thanks for having me.
-This is very exciting.
Since the last time I saw you,
you are a mother
for the first time.
You celebrated
your first Mother's Day.
-I know. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Baby turning one next week?
-Yeah, on Tuesday.
That was quick.
-Do you have big plans?
Big birthday plans?
-Well, you know,
she made all these friends.
-I'm so sorry.
-In Central Park,
at the playground.
Yeah, she has a busier
social calendar than I do.
-That's fantastic.
-So she's having a party
with her friends --
like, a little music party.
-That's excellent.
I'm very, very happy for you.
Congratulations.
-Thanks.
-So, this show --
so, this is a real person.
This is a story
about a real person
that basically was famous
from a billboard first.
Can you tell us
a little bit about her?
-Yeah, she's kind of
a little bit of a --
she's, like, a unicorn
in Los Angeles.
She rose to power in the '80s
through a series
of mysterious billboards
that popped up, featuring this
incredibly provocative woman,
kind of laying
in this provocative pose,
just her name and a phone number
for management.
And suddenly, overnight,
they started to multiply,
until there were 200 billboards
and a 10-story wall.
And she would drive around L.A.,
and still does,
in this pink Corvette,
with the hair and the body
and the really
incredibly honed style.
And she was the first person
to kind of raise her hand
and say, "I am famous.
And I am an enigma.
I am a mystery."
And to be celebrated
for who she is and
not something that she does.
-And how old were you
when you were first hip to her,
as a thing?
-I discovered her
through her billboards
when I was 12 or 13.
I was in L.A.,
auditioning for the first time,
and I saw a billboard.
And the funniest thing about it
was I -- it's almost like,
once you see it,
you just start
to see it everywhere.
And so I would ask people,
"Who is this woman, Angelyne?"
And they would all be like, "Oh,
my God, Angelyne, I love her."
And I would say,
"What does she do?
Like, what's her story?"
And everyone would say
a completely different story.
She was from space.
She was from Ohio.
There were 12 of her.
There was some rich guy
who paid for the billboards.
She was a man.
There is 12 of her.
You can rent them out
for a party.
They switch them out every year.
Just wild stories.
And throughout, like,
she was so hip and smart,
'cause she knew that she never
contradicted any of the stories.
They only fueled her fame.
And really that was her pursuit,
the love of the world.
-And so you embark on this
project to tell her story.
You got to meet
the real Angelyne.
What was that like?
-Yeah, I was so far down the
rabbit hole by that point.
I was so kind of
deeply enamored of her
and kind of her feminine power
and her kind of protesting
the patriarchy in her way.
I got this meeting with her
to talk about potentially
doing this show,
and I showed up an hour early,
and she was on time.
But then, she sells merch
out of her car --
T-shirts and skateboards
and stuff
with her face on them,
and people buy them.
They pay -- She doesn't give
selfies for free, guys.
-Wow.
-She charges $50 for a selfie.
And if you want the fan,
she covers her face with a fan.
But if you want the fan down,
it's more.
-Really?
-Uh-huh.
So she ended up an hour late
to the meeting,
because I could see she was,
like, swarmed with fans,
selling merch, which I loved.
-Yeah.
-And then,
when she finally sat down,
she laid a napkin on the chair
and she kind of
delicately sat down
and kind of posed in her way.
And then she said, "So,
why do you have such a hard-on
to play me?"
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "That's why."
'Cause she's a real badass.
-Yeah.
-She is a feminist
in the most unexpected way,
and she's totally unapologetic.
-You do not look like her.
-No.
-So, to play her, obviously,
you had to go through
a transformation.
I would assume
it took a great amount of time
to get into this character.
-Yes. Yes.
It was a very long process
with prosthetics and
a hair-and-makeup team.
And you know,
there's kind of latex
and various stages of things.
-How long?
-Well, some hours in the
contemporary-day makeup
was like seven hours, some days.
-Wow!
-Yeah. So, a long time.
But really, they're painting you
and sculpting you
like you're the Sistine Chapel.
-Yeah.
-Really, I mean, there was
PVC piping in my nose.
There's stuff in my mouth.
My ear lobes aren't my ears.
There's two contact lenses
in each eye.
But it's so fun.
-When you look in the mirror
afterwards,
is it jarring?
-Well, at first it's --
You know, when they
spun me around,
it's almost like dissociative.
Like you don't see yourself,
and you're speaking in a voice
that doesn't sound like yours
and saying dialogue
that isn't yours.
And it's -- At first,
it's, like, unsettling.
It's terrifying.
And then it's, like,
this freedom that comes
with, like,
"Oh, I can go far with this.
I can stretch
and I can play here.
And this is fun."
-Really, you must feel safer
to take giant swings,
because it's almost feels
like you're doing it
on behalf of somebody else.
-Yeah, and I think
what was so fun about this
is the story of,
like, talking about her,
playing her as an icon,
not a person,
and all throughout history,
all the people
that tried to tell her story
and co-opt her narrative,
and so the show is kind of
this very unconventional
storytelling,
'cause she is unconventional.
And we see
different versions of her,
depending on
who is telling the story.
So it was fun to play
all the different versions
of what she might have been.
-Not just from other
people's perspective,
but over the course of 50 years.
So I would assume
you've never played a character
that has this --
-No.
-As far as the amount of years
the scope was.
-No, aging in both directions.
-Right.
-Tape and string.
[ Laughter ]
Yep.
-Your husband, Sam,
who's a very talented
television producer and writer,
he was a producer
on this, as well.
-He was.
-Have you guys --
What was it like,
collaborating with him on this?
-It was so fun.
Although, he did come to set and
did not know what to make of it,
'cause it was just not me
anymore.
-Yeah.
-But, you know,
you rehearse something
for so long,
you do it more hours of the day
than you're not doing it.
So, you come home
and you're making eggs
at the end of the day
for, like, a quick dinner,
and you find yourself
kind of doing
all this stuff
that's so foreign to you.
But you're not in it anymore,
but you're still in it.
-Yeah.
-So, it's just this --
Yeah, it kind of permeates
your home life a bit.
-You worked with
a parakeet, correct?
-Yes.
-How was that?
-You know,
I like making it hard.
-Yeah.
-I really do.
It's always fun.
-Was the parakeet hard?
-Most professional actor
I've ever worked with.
-Really?
-Yeah.
Hit their mark
every single time.
Had been in movies,
well-trained, yeah.
-Did you retroactively
think less
of the human actors
you'd worked with,
every time
you worked with the parakeet?
-Less of myself.
[ Laughter ]
No, I think it's so fun
to work with animals.
I think, anytime -- I like to
eat in scenes, too, though.
I like to be challenged.
-Yeah, do it all.
Hey, congratulations.
It is such a unique show.
And it's really cool
that you told this story.
And thanks so much
for being here.
-Thank you.
-Always such a pleasure.
You guys, Emmy Rossum!
All episodes of "Angelyne"
are available now on Peacock.